[Music]
hello again I'm Dustin Kirkland a
product manager at Google and I'm here
with one of my colleagues David
Oppenheimer he's a software engineer
working on multi-tenancy in kubernetes
at Google David I've got a couple of
questions for you about multi-tenancy in
kubernetes I was at coop con a year ago
in Berlin and multi-tenancy was quite
the topic what have you heard over the
last year in terms of customer and user
demands around multi-tenancy in
kubernetes yeah so a year ago it was
very popular for people to just run lots
of clusters if they had different users
who or applications who they wanted to
isolate from one another and over the
last year we've either introduced or
brought to a greater level of maturity
like beta or GA a bunch of features in
open source kubernetes that enable
multi-tenancy within a cluster within a
single cluster so that's a big change
because I've seen this as well every
team every department gets their own
kubernetes cluster they're completely
separate separate management planes so
you're saying that as of kubernetes 110
now I should be able to run multi tenant
multiple tenants in a single cluster
yeah that's right so like some of the
features that we have that are mature
now are the most well-known one is our
back for authorization so you can put
very fine-grained controls over which
users or groups of users or applications
can create and update and delete which
API resources on the API server and so
that kind of gives you control plane
isolation and then we also have other
features that provide isolation on the
node or the container level for example
we have pod security policy which says
oh it's an administrators say for
example no privilege containers in this
cluster or in this namespace or you
can't run any containers this route in
this in this namespace or these these
users can't can't do that
so give you a pretty fine grained
control over what privileges containers
running in the cluster have and then
another policy that's kind of at the
node level is network policy which
controls which pods can communicate with
which other pods so that you can for
example isolate namespaces from one
another or say that you have like part
of your application in one
space and party for application in
another name space and the pods that
constitute that application should be
able to talk to each other across that
namespace boundary but not with other
namespaces in the cluster and so you can
kind of partition your cluster based on
the groups of users and the applications
and the topology of the application
using using network policy so between
those three features the are back and
the network policy in the pod security
policy we've kind of met a lot of the
needs that people have for multi-tenancy
for running like enterprises or
software-as-a-service where you want to
provide isolation between untrusted
users sharing a cluster so now it's
realistic for Coke and Pepsi as separate
tenants to run in the same in the same
cluster that feels reasonable at this
point well so Coke and Pepsi is kind of
going to one extreme of the spectrum and
so one of the things that people have
asked a lot about and actually there's
been just very recent technology
developed around solving that problem is
kind of a hypervisor level of isolation
between containers so when I was talking
about like pod security policy and
network policy earlier those are kind of
based on the container isolation in
docker or whatever runtime you're using
and also what your network provider can
provide for the network policy but it
doesn't give you the you still have
shared multiple containers on a node are
still sharing the same kernel and so if
you want the level of protection that
you need say for Coke and Pepsi then you
should use something like gee visor
which was announced today or yesterday I
guess that from Google which allows you
to have kind of the hypervisor level of
security and isolation between
containers that are sharing a cluster
and so I think that for the Coke and
Pepsi use case now it's available now
it's possible to do that but that's a
very recent development that's great and
in terms of what's coming next and you
give us maybe a brief taste of where the
where multi clusters and multi-tenancy
has headed in in kubernetes sure there's
kind of two areas where there's ongoing
work for multi-tenancy one of them is
related to policies so making it easier
for people to
specify these policies today you kind of
have to be a bit of an expert in
kubernetes in order to know how to set
up the multi tendency policies in a
multi-tenant cluster so some of the work
that's going on is kind of towards
unifying and making it simpler to
specify the the different policies and
then we also have work that it's kind of
not not related to policies but more
related to isolation so for example
improving the isolation between tenants
in the control plane so for example
different users can't dos each other by
overloading the scheduler overloading
the API server so giving the controllers
and the other components of the
kubernetes control plane some notion of
how much of the control plane resources
each tenant is using so that it can kind
of fairly share the resources across
those tenants or at least prevent them
from bossing each other and ensure that
all the tenants can make progress even
if one of them is trying to impose a lot
of load on the schedule or the API
server or some other piece of the
control plane so that's one of the one
of the key things that we're working on
now to improving the multi tendency
story yeah it's super impressive how far
we've come in a year and I'm really
looking forward to where we're going
next David thank you yeah thanks
you